in light of the election of president
elect Donald I thought it would be
useful and I don't even need to spell it
out I think you'll understand the
connection to review our July of 2014
interview with Jon Ronson about his book
how to spot a psychopath I don't need to
belabor the introduction to this classic
interview anymore I think it is very
very relevant given the election of
Donald as well as many of the deplorable
--hz that are rapidly making them their
way into Trump's potential cabinet and
set of advisers my July of 2014
interview with Jon Ronson how to spot a
psychopath I'm joined today by Jon
Ronson who is the New York Times
bestselling author of the psychopathy
test a very very interesting book Jon
great to have you with us let's start
first how did you get interested in the
topic of psychopathy um I met this woman
who was married to a guy who claimed to
be from the CIA and for seven years she
lived as a CIA wife I'd he'd go off to
you know Gaza and then after seven years
she got a telephone call from somebody
saying that you know every time he
thought he was going off to Gaza he was
actually going off to his other wife's
house which was like about a mile down
the road and I said - he got he must
have been so upset and she said she said
more no he's a psychopath and so does
the wildebeest feel upsets when it's
being chased by the lion you know the
wildebeest knows that it's in the lions
nature to act that way and that's struck
me as like such a huge thought that
there were people out there who were
like lions like so cold killers and I
never met a psychologist who said that
that particular brain anomaly
psychopathy is so powerful that it
reiden society all wrong that you're
muchly or four times more likely to have
psychopaths at the top of a tree they do
I have wondered they at the bottom so
again that struck me as like a massive
thought that that Psychopaths ruled the
world and I don't know whether whether I
believed it or not but it struck me such
a huge thought I thought sugar baby
garden on a journey to try and find out
and certainly the the book kind of
catalogs that journey
and what would you how would you define
psychopathy host book in other words how
did the process of researching and
writing the book change your your
assessment of what a psychopath is if it
did yeah I think it did and I think I
think it kind of continues to mutate I
went on a course to I went on a course
to learn how to spot Psychopaths
I am now certified in it and that I've
got certificate of attendance which is
by the way enough to you know make you a
court expert in certain american de
states which is a bit worrying because i
could barely do it but um so so okay so
scientifically if you want to use that
term there's twenty ways of identifying
a psychopath it the main one is lack of
empathy but also there's things that
lack of remorse grandiose sense of
self-worth glibness superficial charm
and so on and there's a gold standard of
psychopathy diagnosis which is a
checklist called pcl out which is used
in courtrooms and sentencing hearings
and so on and I believe that the
inventor of the checklist is really you
know done done an extraordinary thing
because psychopathy it you know
Psychopaths da say that's totally normal
you know they fake empathy and they're
you know they fake caring so so it's
done a really great job but but then
what you begin to realize is it there's
an awful lot of people out there who
were just desperate to diagnose
everybody that they don't like is
psychopaths and these are people you
know who have the same certification
that I have and have power and so as the
years of God I've started to think well
you know maybe a psychopath is just
another way of saying you know somebody
that we really don't like right what one
one of the factors that I was very
interested in is this concept of a
Psychopaths are good at manipulating the
emotions of others and it may be out of
a desire of some kind of personal desire
it may be for other reasons however
there are many people who learn the
skill if we are to call it a skill or
maybe ability
is a better term to manipulate the
emotions of others and this ranges from
people in various types of sales fields
we've talked with recently a social
engineer who's a professional whose job
is to go in and try to manipulate others
to test security for example the test
corporate security so the the ability or
skill of manipulating others emotion
alone I feel like a lot is made of that
when evaluating psychopathy while there
it may not really be that good of an
indicator or am i off on that well okay
so so a an expert in psychopathy
somebody who's tried to utilize the
checklist will say that's an important
indicator but it's not enough there's
like twenty items on the checklist right
add to be you know past the cutoff point
really have to score on like 15 of the
20 indicators but that's not to say that
some aren't considered more important
than others and and it's true cutting
manipulative is one of the big items on
on the checklist I remember I went to
see our Dunlap chainsaw al Dunlap the
notorious asset stripper from the 1990s
I would say about his grand Florida
mansion and I went through the
psychopath checklist with him because he
was named in Fast Company magazine as a
kind of quintessential corporate
psychopath and when I got to cutting
manipulative he said well that's
leadership uh so he was kind of
redefining that's activism as a
leadership positive let's take that
example though of this of the corporate
CEO because I think that's an
interesting one
there's this idea of course that that uh
high-powered politicians and
high-powered CEOs are are significantly
more likely to be psychopaths than kind
of the average person I'd be curious in
your in your opinion how does the the
real life so to speak psychopaths in one
of those positions differ from the kind
of caricature of psychopathy that's
often portrayed in film or in fiction
art are they more similar or are they
more different well they tend not to be
killers like violent Psychopaths that
that seems to be a if you believe the
statistic that four percent of CEOs a
Psychopaths that's Robert hare statistic
right it is the kind of the inventor of
the checklist you know that's an awful
lot of psychopaths in power and very few
of them become become violent although I
think hair would say that they all
become malevolent that they're the sort
of people it's kind of like hedge funds
it's it's the sort of journalism the
kind of place where you can go in and
make a make a quick kill you know go in
get what you want to then get out
because another item on the checklist is
proneness to boredom so I don't think
you're gonna I don't think you Richard
Branson's and so on would ever qualify
because people who kind of slowly it
assiduously build up a business over
decades you know that's not a
psychopathic trait I should say that
even our Dunlap who was named by Fast
Company is like the kind of classic
corporate psychopath even he didn't fit
into the box quite as well as most
people would like because he said that
he wasn't a juvenile delinquent he got
accepted at West Point
he's only been married twice so he
doesn't score high on many short term
marital relationships or risky or sexual
behavior you know there's no allegations
of that so even when you find yourself
with with what some people would
consider a kind of classic one they're
never quite as classic as you as you
think they're going to be and and I
think that speaks to the sort of
slightly suck psychopathic way that we
want to like desperately define people
as Psychopaths right well that was that
was where I was going next which is is
the desire to categorize people within a
binary way so to speak you either are or
are not this thing is that even a Riz
that even useful to us or does
psychopathy exist on a sort of spectrum
well I mean to me this is the most
fascinating question of all this is even
more fascinating than whether or not
Psychopaths rule the world
because even though clinicians will
always say it exists on a spectrum you
know everybody's everybody goes from
zero
to 1440s the top mark what Robert hare
once said to me is that when you meet
you know what do you meet a real one
it's it's stunning you know like a
high-scoring one and I think that's true
I think it is studying when you meet
them however there is this desperate
desire in psychology and psychiatry and
the pharmaceutical business and
journalism and social media to kind of
declare other people insane there's like
this desperate desire to kind of you
know label people in this binary way as
you said and to me that's fascinating
because that's something that we all do
I mean my god the number of times people
have asked me if Lance Armstrong is a
psychopath and sholden and after a while
you start to feel well this is kind of
corrosive you know the way that we we
just want to turn human beings into
these one-dimensional figures
well the Lance Armstrong example is very
interesting to me because where I was
going next was in in limited
interactions with people that you meet I
I will sometimes talk to people who will
describe sort of characteristics that
made them think they had met a
psychopath and for me they're the same
characteristics that might decide to
find someone more likely as a narcissist
than a psychopath in other words I think
that psychopathy is a much more
significant definition of someone and
and in casual interactions with people I
think some of the characteristics of
psychopathy may just be narcissism yes
I'd say so
again I think somebody like hare would
say that you know narcissism comes in to
psychopathy but doesn't define psychotic
thing you know it's narcissism plus a
lack of empathy narcissism you know plus
many purpose Q a sexuality which I was
think is a kind of weird word to have on
the checklist because it's been a long
time but I've got to look back about the
spurious sexual days with some fondness
but um but yes so they certainly are
narcissistic like one of the main items
on the checklist is grandiose sense of
self-worth right I remember when I was
at our Dunlap's house and I asked him
why think that grandiose sense of
self-worth we both kind of involuntarily
looked up
because he was standing underneath a
giant or you're painting with himself so
narcissism is certainly part of it but
it's really in some ways I think it can
be defined by what's not there what's
not there is is empathy and kind of fear
you know that that feeling and that you
get when somebody leaps out in front of
you and you know kind of debilitating
feeling of shark you know all the things
that make you good like a good person a
guilt remorse they don't have that stuff
um and I've certainly over the years met
people who would be considered
high-scoring Psychopaths but I've also
met an awful lot of people who have been
labeled Psychopaths who are kind of you
know troubles and good people I think is
it I think it's a very overused
diagnosis certainly so we've been
speaking with Jon Ronson the book is the
psychopathy test thank you so much for
joining us today a real pleasure
thanks David I enjoyed it